in an office relationship it's special
um she's nice she's shy
she's actually here if you want to meet
her one thing oh my god put on a shirt
but I told you that you'd be on camera
I'm sorry she's European
no I told you that he'd be on camera
stop making progress yes so I tried to
kiss me what and I didn't tell anyone
cuz I'm not really sure how I feel about
it that is not true redacted redacted
well I'm not actually making a formal
complaint I just really think we should
talk about it okay question when a name
is withdrawn does that also apply to the
permanent misbehavior file in New York
sure I'm just saying that you can't be
sure that it wasn't you
that's ridiculous of course it wasn't me
marijuana is a memory loss drugs I mean
I just don't remember I would remember
well how could you of it just erased
your memory that's not how it works no
how do you know how it works
knock it off okay I'm interviewing yo
you said that I'd be conducting the
interview when I walked in here now
exactly how much pot did you smoke so
this year for the first time ever I got
Pam in Secret Santa
and I got her this teapot which I know
she really wants so she went to eat her
desk but I'm also gonna stuff it with
some inside jokes like this is my high
school yearbook photo she sat at the
party and it really makes her laugh not
sure why um else ooh this is a hot sauce
packet she put this on a hot dog a
couple years ago because she thought it
was ketchup and it was really funny so I
kept the other two this would take a
little too long to explain so I won't
and this is a card because Christmas is
the time to tell people why you feel hey
how's it going good
especially after I took all your money
yeah
hey about when you want to give me more
your money did you wanna do that now we
can go inside feeling kind of tonight I
was just um
I'm in love with you
what I'm really sorry if that's weird
for you to hear but I need you to hear
it
probably not good timing I know that I
just what are you doing
could he expect me to say to that
I'm just need you to know once
well I
I
I can't
yeah you have no idea
talk about what your friendship needs to
be
I don't want to do that I want to be
more than that I can't
I'm really sorry
if you misinterpreted things
it's probably my fault
not her fault
I'm sorry I misinterpreted our
friendship
okay okay I ate a tuna sandwich on my
first day so Andy started calling me a
big tuna I don't think any of them
actually know my real name Margaret I
know you just got yourself kicked out of
your apartment
oh I haven't Karen I don't really like
that place that much anyway I'll just
move oh really who's gonna take you in
your messy you're a klutz you spill
everything and you leave the volume on
the TV way to them yeah maybe I'll just
move in with my boyfriend cuz he's kind
of a slob - okay here let's do it
no I am well I'm not gonna and I'm not
gonna move in with anyone unless I'm
engaged
have I not proposed - yeah I don't
oh no well that's coming oh right now no
I'm not gonna do it right here that
would be rather lame okay so then when
Pam am I gonna tell you I hate to break
it to you but that's not how that works
oh right yeah hey I'm serious it's
happening okay
and when it happens it's going to kick
your ass easily so stay sharp I've been
warned
I am not kidding
added a week after we started dating
seriously innocent back yeah that's the
safest part of a car in the event of a
crash driver always protects his side
first here's going to happen I am going
to have to fix you manage you two on a
more personal scale a a more micro form
of Management Jim what is that called
micro Drummond
boom yes now Jim is going to be the
client Dwight you're going to have to
sell to him without being aggressive
hostile or difficult let's go alright
fine ring ring hello
hello this is Dwight Schrute from the
Dunder Mifflin paper company well that's
great because I need paper excellent
then you are in luck because we are
having a limited time offer only on
everything wow this is my lucky day what
is your name sir I am Bill buttlicker
really that's your real name
how dare you my family built this
country by the way you're respectful 20
please yes Michael did you hold on one
second that's my other wine
what no but I hello yeah no I'm just on
the phone this stupid salesman he's so
dumb probably just gonna keep him on the
line forever and not buy anything okay
it's up to you to change mine sorry that
was a family emergency oh no what's
wrong
you know what that's private boundaries
Dwight oh I'm sorry mr. buttlicker as I
was saying so we're having a limit of a
little bit louder I'm hard of hearing
sorry if he's an old man okay as I was
saying right now we're at like louder
okay our prices have never been lower
when you have to talk loud never been
lower louder son but maker our prices
I've never
lower stop hate that is totally
inappropriate
you should never yell at the guy no you
listen to me sir here we go the three
words I would describe you as is
aggressiveness hostile and definitely
difficult please mister by my right
right you know the phones give me the
can give me the phone mr. buttlicker me
the phone
I have to put on with my boss well I
should hope so who is this hello this is
Michael Scott regional manager well this
is William M buttlicker
hello mr. buttlicker how may we help you
Michael I like the sound of your voice
you know I'm gonna do I'm gonna buy 1
million dollars worth of paper products
today
yeah that's top thank you very much sir
I don't think you'll regret it did he or
the mask there is one condition Michael
yes you have to fire the salesman that
treated me so terribly don't do it
Michael well well well look what the cat
dragged in from Stamford a Dwight fact I
am older I am wiser do not mess with me
okay sounds good
what are you doing I don't know jack
i'ma have a spider my forehead
oh look good why you lookin my forehead
well not meet my eye line Jim I am stop
acting like an idiot hey buddy
hey Dwight send in the subs Oh
we were going to choose team names
Dwight we will be called Gryffindor
really not slipping
so there are another bad guys Jim I know
okay we will be Baltimore he who must
not be named I wouldn't do that
bold more okay bold bold Elisha me say
balls
you